[Music]
every two seconds someone somewhere in
the world experiences a stroke and one
out of every six people will have one at
some point in their lives
strokes deprive brain cells of oxygen
and are one of the most common causes of
death and a leading cause of preventable
disability when someone experiences a
stroke quick medical care is critical
and can often help avoid permanent brain
damage but what causes strokes in the
first place and what conductors do to
treat them
the brain makes up just 2% of your
body's mass but consumes more than 20%
of the oxygen in your blood that oxygen
is carried to the brain through a system
of arteries carotid arteries supply the
front of the brain and vertebral
arteries supply the back these are
connected to each other and divide into
smaller and smaller vessels that get
billions of neurons the oxygen they need
if the blood flow is interrupted oxygen
delivery stops and brain cells die there
are two ways this can happen hemorrhagic
strokes are when a perforated vessel
allows blood to leak out but the more
common type is the ischemic stroke when
a clot blocks a vessel and brings blood
flow to a halt where do these clots come
from on rare occasions a sudden change
in heart rhythm prevents the upper
chambers of the heart from contracting
normally this slows down blood flow
allowing platelets clotting factors and
fibrin to stick together the clot can be
carried up towards the arteries and
blood vessels supplying the brain until
it gets to one it can't squeeze through
this is called an embolism and it cuts
off the oxygen supply to all the cells
downstream the brain doesn't have pain
receptors so you can't feel the blockage
itself but oxygen deprivation slows
brain function and can have sudden
noticeable effects for example if the
affected area is responsible for speech
and individuals words may be slurred if
the stroke affects a part of the brain
that controls muscle movement it can
cause weakness often just on one side of
the body when this happens the body will
immediately try to compensate by
diverting blood flow to the affected
area but this isn't a perfect solution
eventually the oxygen deprived cells
will start to die leading to brain
damage that may be severe or permanent
that's why it's important to get medical
care as fast as possible the first line
of treatment is an intravenous
medication called tissue plasminogen
activator which can break up the blood
clot and allow blood to flow again in
the compromised artery if it's delivered
within a few hours
this medication greatly increases the
chance of surviving the stroke and
avoiding permanent consequences if
tissue plasminogen activator cannot be
given because the patient is on certain
medications
has history of major bleeding or the
clot is particularly large doctors can
perform a procedure called an
endovascular thrombectomy using a
fluorescent dye that illuminates the
blood vessels under a strong x-ray the
physician inserts a long thin flexible
tube called a catheter into an artery in
the leg and maneuvers it all the way to
the blockage a retriever is passed
through this catheter it expands and
anchors into the clot when it's just
past it the catheter then pulls the clot
out when it's removed
these treatments need to be delivered as
soon as possible to preserve brain
function which means figuring out fast
if someone is having a stroke so how can
you tell here are three quick things to
try one ask the person to smile a
crooked mouth or facial drooping can
indicate muscle weakness to ask them to
raise their arms if one drifts downward
that arm weakness is also a sign of a
stroke 3 ask them to repeat a simple
word or phrase if their speech sounds
slurred or strange it could mean that
the language area of their brain is
oxygen deprived
this is sometimes called the fast test
and the T stands for time if you see any
of those signs call emergency services
right away lives may depend on it we're
on a nonprofit mission to revolutionize
education click here to learn how you
can get involved
[Music]